you had someone sitting in this room out
here this beautiful Lobby who had never
written a screenplay and you were gonna
give them a five-minute screenplay
lesson at five minutes how would you
start it well I would just tell them I
would say I'd asked them if they had an
idea and then I would just say pull out
your laptop or your notebook with your
pen and start writing it I wouldn't I
wouldn't even tell them about format I
would just be like described a movie
everybody knows what a movie is
everybody knows everybody's seen it
they're like our visual vocabulary is so
high
especially now 2018-2019 I mean you know
anybody can describe it that the problem
is we still when we start educating
people we're like read six books six
books take this course do this stuff
watch this video you know it gets like
but not this video yeah yeah no I need
you can watch this video but that's what
I would do if somebody was like I want
to write a movie and I don't know
anything about it I'd be like what do
you want to write about like what's your
idea and they probably have the idea
they're not like well I don't know what
the idea is though they're gonna be like
well actually I want to write off this
guy who wants to do this thing and I'd
be like okay start describing it just
describe it and then I might say
something like Trudeau don't talk up
don't describe their thoughts and don't
describe their feelings any character
don't describe the insides just describe
what you would see on a movie screen you
know just like and you know exterior
house day man walks across and gets in
the car drives away you know do not care
about doing anything wrong
just spill your guts just tell us the
movie write down the whole movie we'll
figure all that other stuff later you
can figure out where things are supposed
to be later you can figure out
everything I mean you know there's so
many stories about that where they
didn't know what they were doing you
know they wrote bridesmaids that way
they didn't know white they brought they
bought screenwriting for dummies or
something like that
right so it's like that fresh voice it's
like ah it breaks my heart thinking
about all the people that have that
think they have because we've created
this industry where it's all coded and
they got to go take oh you got to learn
you have to learn structure you have to
learn this you've got to learn all these
things you gotta know what a screenplay
is man you got to know what the rules
are before you break them that's all
crap to sell books and all sorts of
stuff it doesn't it's it we God please
bring them in that don't know anything
about movies and maybe we'll have better
movies I mean that's the problem it's
like it's like all this other stuff it's
like bringing that person it's just like
I have as a teacher I have had people
come in with formatting that's just like
doesn't know they don't know what they
don't have access to final trap I don't
know what they're writing and it's the
most authentic slice of life funny
succinct observational genius stuff and
they don't and if the reason why it
exists is because they haven't learned
anything about screenwriting yet and
then once you start teaching them then
all of a sudden they they don't know
what they're doing then they don't then
they lose their emotional connection
they lose that story four year olds know
how to tell a story they know how to
tell a story ask a five-year-old what
happened today at school well we went in
beginning middle and end the inciting
incident you can tape it you can go
exciting that's it so you guys should
film curse do should interview a
frigging ten-year-old and then put the
little Flags in and be like wow they
know all the structure already so I
don't have to go to so-and-so person's
course or I don't have to take Gordy's
class or anything you know you don't
have to spend any money and keep your
voice that's the most important thing I
was at it's like don't lose your voice
don't lose your instincts your childlike
instincts for telling stories it's like
that's what guides us and I always go
back to that I'm like I don't care the
thing I just wrote for somebody that
we're all likelihood people are watching
the
video we'll see I don't know what the
structure is I don't know where the act
brakes are today and it's over a hundred
and fifty pages okay it was a writer I
mean and it's probably gonna be seen by
people watching this video directed by a
very very good top director this is
going to happen and I have no idea what
the structure of that is I literally
just took my ideas plotted out the thing
now am i following the rules of
character and emotional engagement to
like develop and everything things you
can reflect back on it be like how do I
make this better but when you're telling
me when somebody's like what's the
five-minute version of like somebody
wants to write a movie that's they watch
this video what I just sit
you